chauffe pas
y'a pas à dire
c'est lequel sur le dernier album on a
quoi aujourd'hui au quartet deux violons
un rappeur coûte je le mette sur les
cordes et puis je veux pas de champ
exxon nous avons pas indifférent ça va
être tranquille
bonjour alors pas près d'être soit votre
salle est chaud et de quotas et en fait
j'ai un concept de latin c'est que je
faire un featuring sauf que le futur et
je peux pas faire tout seul donc moi
jana rappeur pourquoi après ben je puis
ça le futur et a fait tirer dessus
jacques d'échappement leçon monsieur on
va le faire ce sens et bah répète après
moi alors on va le faire on va le faudra
le faire on va le faudra le faire qu'on
va le faire encore plus fort à faire on
va le faire a vraiment pas beau d'abord
affaire vaut le faire faire ce soir je
le fais je le fais un gâchis berlin fin
du mois
là j'y vois tu vois là c'est le juge l'a
dit jma mais l'astuce de boussole en
californie quand on est parti donc je
prends la lamborghini hardcore comme un
me suis en bikini levé les mains en
l'air
conçu dans les parages mais je suis
millionnaire et je suis au chômage à
temps ou nîmes si les photos de
bâtiments reno nevada sur hollywood
boulevard
j'amène le fric que la magie et paoua
guillaume pepy g jamais ne l'excitent la
mayo bien gêné d'avoir des profonds
faisait face à lui le grand canyon c'est
qu'une fissure la mère nature c'est
afrique
mais dites vous aux litiges family
j'assume
m
la famille
dans le secteur suit le dentaire même ta
grand-mère romain on peut extraire les
flics me connaissent ils me laissent
faire
même quand je prends le métro je suis en
classe affaires qu'en mon que son alerte
à malibu secours sur la plage puis gaulé
comme l'allemagne ou jetons patrouille
moi j'en dirais qu'on entends tu vends
mes chouchous
les fous
m
la note de bâtard
non
oh
o o
eto'o